do you actually think that trans women
and intersex women are real women this
clip is really interesting so again this
is from about a year ago he had a trans
activist on and watch his just absolute
inability to say what is true with any
degree of conviction as he's hearing a
whole bunch of nonsense
this issue people like to say that it's
a complicated issue and I don't actually
think it is I think it's very simple it
all boils down to do you actually think
that trans women and intersex women are
real women
and are really female or not and if you
do it's very simple just stop policing
who counts as a real woman because this
has had history of racism built into it
over the years it's not an accident that
the intersex athletes who get singled
out are women of color from the global
South because who gets singled out for
scrutiny is based on white women's
conceptions of femininity and that's
being weaponized against trans people
too so it's a fear of protecting the
fragile weak CIS white woman from the
rest of us so so
there are many elements to what you've
said which I appreciate so let's try
break them down
one thing that confuses me personally is
it it seems like we have discussions
about who should participate in which
category and how
you know on the face of it it seems
simple as you say you know if somebody
identifies as a woman if they're
transgender they can compete against
women who are born biologically and and
then if not then not but then there are
many who would argue who are not
transphobes there are many who who born
biologically women who say but you have
an unnatural advantage over me and that
makes the sport unfair how do you
respond to that yeah there's lots of
ways you can respond to that so the
first is the the very language of you
were born and I'm not biological somehow
like I don't think I'm a cyborg so like
this idea that like oh you're not a
biological woman well I am a woman
that's a fact I am female so all my
identity records my racing license my
medical records I'll say female right
and I'm pretty sure I made a biological
stuff so I'm a biological female as well
so this question of do trans women have
an advantage over CIS women
we don't know
um in fact there's basically no
published research on this question
however uh there's good reason to think
that there isn't
but I think it's irrelevant because we
allow all kinds of competitive
advantages within women's sport okay
first off that is a dude
you know dressed or acting as a woman
complaining that white women are the
problem so irony is dead we all get that
my issue and why I wanted to show you
this is you see how he can't just defend
what is obviously true and instead of
even him saying well I think actually
because it's fairly obvious to me if you
got that guy in a room he would say I
don't know if he has kids but he
wouldn't want his five-year-old daughter
competing against five-year-old boys
right like it's just freaking obvious
but you see he won't defend it on his
own Merit right because he's just a
servant of the machines there are people
who say that you shouldn't do this or
that also I don't know what she's
talking about about how most of the
people who have been discriminated
against have been black intersex
athletes boy can I get the list on that
can you go to Black
intersexathlete.net and let me get the
full list on that we'll see if we can
get that for you but again it's this
inability to just save there's no such
thing as black interest I love it God
bless you God bless you for trying
good people good people uh the point of
all of this is we have a series of
people who will not say what is true and
then when you don't say what is true you
end up just saying a whole bunch of
gibberish